a new USA Today poll about the Russia
investigation has shown that more
Americans trust the Special Counsel than
the Trump administration can you believe
it Annie that's just crazy to me I know
it's crazy but luckily it doesn't seem
like anything has affected Robert
Mueller's investigation I'm sorry Annie
did you say Mueller yeah Robert Mueller
no it's not pronounced Mueller Andy it's
Muller
oh I mean how am I supposed to remember
that it's quite simple Andy very simple
music please when you're biting on a
cruller
just remember Robert Muller and that
should ensure that you'll never get it
wrong or there is nothing really crueler
than the call of Muller Muller so before
you say his name think of this song all
right I think I get it
I can think of nothing Tower then folks
mispronouncing Muller heed my word
guarantee you don't say Muller sounds
more like foe and left like FuelBand
Tabo and not a mule say it Muller and
don't be a slack-jawed ruler okay I
totally get it you don't need that's
right it's mother and not Muller don't
rhyme with Ferris Bueller sure as your
name is auntie and not and I throw in
shining Technicolor read this name is
robert muller bless your mouth disco
keep the word a try moer fine hair by
George I think he's getting it
so when you're at the water cooler and
some jackass
chosen you to sing a song will be the
one you set them straight
true they may punch you in the face but
you're the smile that can't erase feel
truthful mention one longview again okay
I completely get it it's Muller not
Muller thanks for explaining it I'm all
set you don't have to sing anymore
because his tops already very hard he
should be held in high regard
he's battle-scarred into holes but the
Constitution's bodyguard he is the one
man Scotland Yard the opposite of a
blowhard he does magic is this your card
Trump's boy stood by his home
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
okay
but is it Rosen Steiner Rosenstein you
Andy
[Music]
you
[Music]
you